sophie turner kicks off her bachelorette
party with Maisie Williams and wigs he
was telling me if she's already starting
to think about what she's gonna wear to
your wedding oh good I don't know why
she's thinking about I'm giving her the
bridesmaid dress she gonna be one of
your bridesmaids
yes she's my maid of honor The Game of
Thrones star is gearing up for wedding
number two to Joe Jonas with a trip to
Spain it's great it's wonderful
and while Sophie's mo hasn't graced us
with any posts yet her other friends
have been busy giving us some serious
FOMO so far the getaway has featured a
private jet complete with champagne and
McDonald's drinks with fun straws and
colorful wigs but not everything has
been smooth sailing
Sophie's friend Blair captioned her
photo of the private plane writing we
can't have nice things
Blair went on to reveal that everyone
filled their McDonald's and drinks on
take off bless that flight attendants
heart she added Turner's Spanish getaway
comes two weeks after Jonas celebrated
his bachelor party in Ibiza you've just
come back for my bathe and surprisingly
you're looking all incredibly good you
got a great night's sleep after a visit
like five hours feels like 13 days the
duo officially tied the knot in Vegas
after the Billboard Music Awards on May
1st
[Music]
you know what it went with this ring
their second wedding is expected to take
place this month in France it's just
like the best support the best person to
calm me down and keep you calm and if I
end up crying I have a shoulder to cry
on so it's good I'm so happy
[Music]